hello welcome to this video playing FM
soft play and who is that no idea okay
the oh wow sometimes what okay what the
what the heck that is an opening hmm
okay so i take c 3 it takes f6
I don't understand that not at all what
is the point here I mean I'm just taking
stuff
Bishop g5 hmm
so I just go to f5 I guess I don't have
I want to be able to play Bishop e7 if
him if he goes Queenie to check check I
guess I have to
but what if we had opening never seen
that so we took them now we canceled so
he wants to go rook e1 and obstruct my
canceling as long as possible I can do
this however rookie one Bishop is six
ya know that should be okay I could even
cancel here right not now then Bishop d3
so it's not i mean this is this is not
good at all but doesn't mean that you
can play any kind of nonsense and win
with black so select to be alert
so currently I'm two pawns up and if i
take on beachwood will be a third
problem
and a very strange opening white is
basically losing after move a door so I
mean maybe I'm wrong I don't know but
that looks entirely incorrect so what
you do now I think taking that should be
ok
so let's see now trying to keep a six is
probably a little bit a little bit too
greedy so I'm going to cancel just
castle and return the six porn
retakes the TS to trade queens which is
basically end of game I think if queens
are traded okay then I cannot take that
i have c 6 if it takes d5 i have c 6
sorry winning you more stuff
ok
knight c6 I can also just go back it
could be a Kim and that's going on c6
let's make sure not to spend enormous
time then that's one of the few
possibilities how I can screw that up
thinking too long and I can completely
winning position where everything goes
so what about this here 9241 no I don't
want to give away a 7 it's no particular
lick good idea hmm
d fibers hanging but is it important
I am thinking for too long here that was
the first idea that I had and somehow I
hesitated for no particular reason by
the way if you recognize that I gained
some rating points between the game
released before that and the game here
that was a wind by desk connection after
four moves somehow sorry my opponents
and connections seem to failed on him
and he lost him lost directly so check
here check and he gonna form back rank
is not especially great routed to as a
move now one of many interesting moves
also just taking is good but why not
you have to look to one I don't have
something particularly particularly
great I can go with you three are things
like that check
if he goes Rudi to
ma'am I cannot win both looks as if
eight is also hanging
check oh that's something that I should
have seen I really didn't so so ever how
is he handling this threatening
promotion and threatening the rook just
have to make sure that I'm not getting
back rank made it that is some somehow
part of this position white reason I've
quindi 80 Jeff if you ask me this is
just entirely incorrect that opening let
let's check there and deform how to
believe and then if I thought about 95
maybe this could be some kind of
Belgrade gambit I don't know it still
shouldn't be good but and this is just
looks entirely wrong engine just gives
castles yeah hmm it would be cool if I
can just cancel out I wasn't I didn't
check fancy this so much but probably it
is just good young as this is not a
problem threatening to take it's a
pretty bad position right
it's pretty awful yeah I could have
considered that but it's just just just
material for nothing check and it's just
not enough compensation yeah maybe Tiki
won't be to first is better but I don't
think it's a big deal talk too long but
if I was good and it's just it's just
pretty pretty powerful something like
that I didn't even see that I can't
clean now and win I was I was just
thinking that this is good something
like and like this is what was my idea
and it seems to win as well it's just a
bit much I've got two parts this is
still existing at 93 is a threat so yeah
it's one of those cases where ever the
early gambits are just entirely
incorrect him okay thanks for watching